whatup Space Frame goes in here from
anime out Pro and wow this is the
craziest development in the water arc
yet make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you enjoy seeing these one piece
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing to do is show one
piece some love I smash that like button
turning it blue and sharing this video
and if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future chapter reviews as we wait
for the next chapter to drop which looks
like it will be in two weeks you can
check out my one piece playlist with
videos about the yong-chol warlord
supernovas and more feel free to leave
suggestions for other videos you would
like to see in the comments obviously
there will be spoilers here I'm covering
chapter 984 afterall now without further
ado let's jump into it remember the last
chapter Yamato appeared to one-shot all
teeth and run away with Luffy Luffy gave
one of the most satisfying punches to
page ones dinosaur form but page one
seems to be fine here as he tells sis
ulti to pull it together there's mention
of getting a doctor in page 1 tell some
underlings to not let Luffy Yamato out
of their sight the flying 6 member wants
to know where they end up so you can
catch up to them and make sure they
don't get away clearly page 1 is doing
really well after what looked like a
devastating ko punch to the jaw the
surrounding beast pirates are pretty
concerned about page 1 understandably
but you got to respect page 1
he just passingly comments on how Luffy
almost dislocated his jaw and the
observers are shocked that he's only
annoyed after such a hit
keep in mind Luffy is a supernova with
the highest bounty the so called 5th
emperor and the man who wants to take
down Kaito and the other Yong ko and
page one is fine after a solid hockey
enhanced punch from point-blank range
it just keeps surprising me how much Oda
is building up the beast pirates
compared to Luffy during these early
moments page 1 is not even close to
being the strongest member of the beast
pirates and yet he's fine after luffy's
punch
what is definitely building up some huge
suspense and making us ask ourselves how
can we possibly take down Kaito and his
whole overpowered crew if he can't even
keep page 1 down I'm not saying Luffy
gave it his all but still it's
impressive how unfazed page 1 is in the
meantime ulti gets up violently calling
the medics
butchers and telling them to get off of
her you can't help but feel sorry for
these poor guys just trying to do their
jobs and probably getting pushed around
for it and you know they don't have a
union or anything kind of ain't allowing
no union but the important thing for us
here is that ulti is up and energetic
she looked like she was out cold but she
seems back to normal now she's hugging
pay paid fiercely as she tends to do
page one tells her to rest if she needs
it but it doesn't look like she does she
calls out Yamato letting us know that
he's using Kaitos thunder bagua she
suggests that Yamato shouldn't be trying
to roll with the grown-ups although he
definitely proved that he can with his
hit even page one notes at this point
that ulti seems fine and ulti insults
the power behind Amato's hit bagua means
eight trigrams and she says the yama
toes hit was more like a sigil meaning
four rather than eight in this way she
lets us know that it was at best half
the strongest kind of attack and
probably even weaker the point is the
snow were close to real thing this makes
sense too because Luffy clearly couldn't
just bounce back like nothing happened
after Kaito hit him the way ulti bounced
back here although there was room last
chapter to believe that Yamato was super
LP here we are getting a better sense of
his own limit especially when compared
to his father as page one rushes off
when told that luffy and Yamato had
stopped moving some bystanders observe
how crazy tough the dinosaur zones are
and yeah they do seem to have a special
level of endurance
even among zones which makes sense since
a dinosaur would be harder to take down
that a cat or bunny for example the
original huge size of most dinosaurs and
they're thick reptile like skin seems to
magnify their defensive capabilities
whether they're inhuman or dino form and
I loved learning about all of these
subcategories of zones like mythical
ancient carnivorous and dinosaur and how
they all compare and contrast with one
another it's a little detail but it's
fascinating stuff we jump to luffy and
finally he's fighting back against
yamato which makes sense it doesn't look
good when the future king of pirates is
just being carried off by his enemies
unwillingly so it's good to see him
actually questioning it luffy rashly
points out that he's not just gonna drop
everything he's doing to follow someone
he doesn't know
luffy is attacking while Yamato is on
the
offensive trying to calm Luffy down and
get him to listen to what he has to say
he wants to talk to him away from the
eyes of other people some beast pirates
mentioned that they were supposed to
stop yamato but they obviously have no
chance not only is he a Mottola beast
but Luffy's fighting means they can't
even approach them without getting hurt
it looks like Yamato is starting to get
annoyed when he calls Luffy a stubborn
little dot-dot-dot
but then he says something interesting
he says this reminds me all the more of
him of our fights together I was
wondering who he meant when I read this
and we know that ace used to be here and
his memory has played a big role in this
arc so I thought that it could be a that
he's referring to unfortunately we don't
get any confirmation here a huge
explosion caused by the fighting takes
place and by the time page 1 arrived the
beast pirates have to admit that they
have lost sight of the two fugitives we
then jumped at a stage where our little
man momonosuke
is being held captive and is about to be
publicly executed like his father or the
pirate king himself he's definitely in
good company at least watching the
hannibal uses his snail-like to let
everyone know that moment no escape
traveled 20 years into the future using
the power of Odin's white talkie he
calls her a witch insulting mama
nosegays mom as he's getting prepared to
execute the kid obviously to some this
sounds pretty outlandish they believe
that the Kisuke were wiped out a long
time ago we see Robin and jinbei who
obviously were able to maintain their
undercover disguises unlike Luffy and
Zorro it's actually pretty funny despite
the fact that it's a dire situation one
of the guys says isn't that right boys
to djembe while patting the ex warlord
on his shoulder and Jimmy plays along
saying wha hahaha sure is you got it and
quote I don't know why but jimbe in
disguise is very funny to me Robin's
very fine self plays along saying she'd
like to dig out mowing loss gaze eyes
but she's actually worried AF she can't
stand seeing mom on the ski like this
and jimbe hopes that Robin can stay
strong long enough for the samurai to
make their move we are then told that
the infiltration force have successfully
infiltrated the banquet wallah and his
friends use laws ability to get to the
rear entrance lost powers are called
incredible jutsu and having just made an
art oh very about two cheetahs I can't
help but appreciate that use of
terminology we get an important meetup
of forces in the reunion of the siblings
ESO and Kiku Marco mentioned seeing a
strange shadow on the sea and he's going
to check it out and that's probably
Paris pero so we have that confrontation
to look forward to
Komatsu brightens up when he sees
nakooma mushi and that's when nakooma
mushi says they made a pit stop to pick
up easel which makes sense because he's
from one oh and would obviously be a
perfect white beard prior for the job
Kiku's teary reaction is very touching
and eso points out how Kiku has become a
splendid samurai he's always clearly the
older sibling here maintaining his
composure but it's clear that this is a
special moment for him too we've then
interrupt the family reunion and jump to
Kyoto titles told that big mom is coming
in Kaito says that he'll make the
announcement alongside moment Oscars
execution I'm guessing this announcement
has to be more than just a confirmation
about their alliance between the two
crews even though it seems to be related
to big mom but more on that later we get
some interesting observations about
kaido's Yong chol presence even his own
underlings say that the mood gets so
heavy when he shows up they feared their
boss who's surrounded by his three
all-stars he says he's gonna spice up
the lame execution somewhat firing shots
at the Royal chief with something
interesting he mentions the new
onigashima initiative and then we jump
places again which kind of sucks cuz we
want to know what he's gonna say so bad
although leaves us wondering for now
though in the attic we got Luffy and
Yamato it would be funny seeing Luffy
just break through the ceiling and land
on the platform right in front of Kaito
and the all-stars but I'm getting ahead
of myself
Luffy agrees to give Yamato five minutes
so he can explain himself and what he
wants we learned that Kaito beat up
Yamato before first saying he wanted to
be close to ki Odin Yamato reveals that
20 years ago he was there and saw the
legendary hour-long execution Yamato was
so frustrated that they killed a
one-of-a-kind samurai like Odin that he
cried then Yamato found Odin's journal
and treated it like a Bible and shoutout
to Odin for proving that keeping a
journal is boss type behavior with the
red scabbards gone
Yamato felt like he was going to carry
on Odin's what
then the mask drops Luffy shocked saying
he thought Yamato is keidel son
Yamato explains that she became a man
because Odin was a man
Yamato comments that Luffy is really
strong and that he hasn't even gotten
serious yet so Yamato wants them to join
forces and reopen the country just like
Odin wanted Yamato is reintroduced as
the daughter of Kaito and
self-proclaimed close wookie Odin
this means that she's not only inherited
order as well but clearly she was also
so inspired by him as to take it to an
extreme and call herself close uki Odin
which is very interesting I quoted
coming up from good at logon in a
previous video saying that real men
don't die even when they're killed and
that is exactly what's happened with
Odin that only has his will carried on
but even his name was carried on by his
rivals daughter you know you're a legend
when you can inspire someone this much
let alone your rivals child and you also
know you're a legend when you turned out
like button blue so you're either a
legend already and I congratulate you or
you can decide to be a legend at any
moment as if Yamato being a pretty
daughter wasn't enough of a shock she
also mentions that Luffy reminds her of
Ace so I was right in assuming that she
was referring to Ace earlier I really
like how this arc has been a kind of
tribute to Ace and his adventures in a
way he's gone but his story continues
for us and for Luffy when luffy says
what that might as well be our own what
at this moment we are all rightly
shocked this chapter was crazy and put
everything we learned before in a new
light Yamato I googled it is more
commonly a Japanese name for males but
it can be a name for females so this
possibility was always right there in
front of us and now when we think about
how she said it Kaito beat her up it was
always messed up but it's even more
messed up now because she was his
daughter
Yamato has kind of horns but it
appearance she looks more like Charlotte
pudding than kaya obviously this can
just be female characters looking alike
but is it possible that she is the
daughter of big mom and Kaito and is
that the announcement or is she now
related but gonna get Wed - someone like
how - Corrie in order to solidify the
alliance we can't be sure what did Kaito
mean by the initiative
he mentioned obviously let me know your
theories in the comments below
big mom did say that Kaito owed her in
the past and some people thought it was
because she looked after Qatar Kuiti who
might have been Kaito son but maybe it's
because she let him keep yamato just
random thoughts thrown out there there
are a million things happening at once
so let me know if I missed something but
wow things are so crazy right now I
cannot wait to see what happens next or
to see Sanji react - Yama those
appearance it looks like close key Odin
is back although not in the flesh
nevertheless a close key Odin lives and
there is hope for 1o yet and that is it
for this chapter review let me know what
you thought of it and what you think
will happen next if you enjoyed it make
sure to smash that like button turn it
blue if you haven't be sure to subscribe
in this crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future what these
videos check out the one piece playlist
link in the description to kill some
time as we wait for the next Chancellor
to come out which looks like it will be
in two weeks
also if you want me to make a specific
one-piece video that you'd like to see
in the playlist leave your suggestions
in the comments below and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]